I'm mentally ill I'm overweight I
isolate people why can't someone just
tell me exactly what to do in a way that
makes it seem like it's my idea I think
that it was at first surprising to
people to see a woman who may be looked
or acted like someone they knew who
didn't have a sort of she nor perfection
of a television character for some
people that was refreshing and for some
people it didn't constitute what they
wanted to see on television I think that
it really brought out a lot of shame in
people who were uncomfortable with their
own bodies and i think that the largest
amount of criticism literally came from
people who were ashamed of what they
look like so it was very annoying to
them that someone could be comfortable
with their body and not look like a
super much like tons i had actually most
like actually we're they have a lot of
friends who are models who were all like
actually would say to me like i'm
inspired by the way that you like own
your own body and then contact my
criticism wasn't from like super fit
people people who had been indoctrinated
with a sense that their own body wasn't
worth looking at
I was most frustrated by criticism of
the physical appearance of some of our
cast specifically Lena and if I'm being
totally honest i would say specifically
other women being critical of Lena's
appearance I that was sort of baffling
to me it was such a great lesson on how
to handle criticism and and more than
criticism how to handle people being
this like straight-up hateful that Lena
was able to just sort of you know put it
in perspective and keep it in
perspective and release or to let it
roll good lesson
[Music]